あ僕山ないです
こちらの
元メンバーの
第一さんがはい
結婚ということになります
[拍手]
jr
をございます
おいてくん
本当に
最近
本当にさんあれでもってるよね
おらっ俺の聞いた話でもいい
いやでも本当にヶ月前くらい本気マジック月マンにも積極れたの
そう1か月前に籍を入れてまだ湿気はやっぱりもこんなご時世腕できてないから様子を
見ながらやるとして
かですけれどそれがなんで想像を動画にしているかといいますと
ふとしたん写真をあげてしまいました作戦よ
世話だって正面から見たらなかっただめだ全然全然なかった
写真撮った画像の中の鏡に大地くんの曲指の指がチラ系ああホント
大佐反応出し方がなかったによって暴かれてめっちゃざーついたって後悔はいがー
恥じる者としてる人だったらいつでも知ってると思うんでもうさばえいじ騒いでそれ
もう日本のトレードに乗ったりすっ
これは何かちゃんと言っておいたほうがいいかなと思って7と改めて撮らせて頂いて
おります
いやめでたいや鳥はいございます
えっ
何人幸運ランディング降雨62人欲しいねをはいいですねやっぱりね昔からの理想で
女の子男の子を知ったいない女の子か
上
2こ下ぐらいに男の受講がないけどだから別に特に
隠す必要とかなかったんだよなんならねーやんなら浮いた方が想像方
別に隠すつもりで言ってなくてたまたまの画像が出て
のアートだったからあのじゃあ
ゆうゆうしかない分私はね特にねその隠し通そうというわけではなかったんだけどなん
か相手も辞めてる身だから愛とこういうしてもないかなと思ったんでまたしてるんです
プレスカブ大竹をしている人がするとあるときではなんかもしれないということでもう
マーズしてお祝いさせて頂いておりましたけどね
どうよ
いけないやうらやましいせよ焦る
俺はねぇ
ここ最近まで目指すんじゃした過去最低までは正直あせってますよ
ああ
コロナという時代になります人となんてやるその伴いではたしかにたしかねそうそうも
ないのに余計ない
焦ったんですけど一周回ってもいいかなと
ああ
あーなろう
そうなっちゃったからもう結婚が
いいやっていう考えまで最近になりますよね
忙しいですしね逆に遊びつくそう
大丈夫かちばる私はフリーランスとしてなろう何古い刃ずフリーランスとしてですね
でも言ってもう28女性はちょっとわからないって言う男はちょうどいいような気も
するよねそうならこの中だと一番
乗りだけど高校の友達とか地元の友達からするともうビリーさんくらいなんだよ
わかる俺高校でバスケ部も前結婚創造総則ないと田舎は早いからね結構おもろい離さが
ですよ
今回作るの嫁さんを決めちゃ
俺がローソンで朝大事な時の後輩なんですよ
オレオとなんでた働いてる時枝さん江田さんは
あのよくサボってたって言ってたいやいやいやあいつあー
別のあのバックの裏でずーったんだろ面白い人って誰
ブーブー面白そうなんだろうなあみたいな
ロス絶見ると恋のキューピットロスがまったく関与してるんですね殺すよ
出会う前ですねの面ではない財産関係はいつ頃をあげられる四季かそうだなぁ
でもやっぱり今時期が時期だから行っても結局はやっぱりホラー
嫁ちゃんの意見としてはやっぱりねえねえやりたいじゃあこんなとしては式っていうの
を
だからややらしてあげたいなっていうのはあるんだけどやっぱりまあ時期が時期だから
ちょっと様子を見つつ
今年中にできたらなあっていうことでできちゃいますねー
林様誕生日だった結構なサービありがとうございます
初めてほんと行ったお祝いコメントが入って本当にああ
まだ見てないいいどうぞ
ran
主婦ってないやスペック覚えていかないんだよ
これ書いてもらったのかいてもらうまだ若いんじゃないですかこれ今回おめでとう
ございますと顔や頭後財産
おはようございます
お祝いもクソもねぇやこれやなんかコメント力くるんですよ
始め焦ってるのっだから君よ follow 合わせてないですもりなさん
逆にも
air pro 切っちゃったね今回のプレつゲストで
に結婚されてる方全廃する人もいますマジでよく読んじゃっていいですか
お願いしますガーなんだよ結婚の先輩プロ佐藤
ございます
ですから普通に働いてるんだ胸にはねそうですね
夫婦の時間をがちゃんと撮れたらいいじゃないんでしょうか
大仕事にのめり込みすぎると無関係悪化していくからね
ああ
japan 釣りですかね一君の伝え奪っきついんじゃねそうなんですよもっと確かに
願いどうすればいいオレはもう仕事を減らす
いやだねそうな2それ本当にもう撮ってくれぱ寂しくなっちゃいまーミニョン中50円
マリオンみんな by あるっていうかんじゃないだろそうなる
と伝丸も実は結婚2人だと発するわけじゃない
そうするとやっぱりどうしてもなんかやっぱ寂しい
clutcho いいんじゃないもの待ってだからね
これは結構二人夫婦なんてか
まとめないからねございゾーンでも一君はやっぱり仕事が
ね充実してるから
ね方は遊びの延長戦ゾンビがございますけどまだ時期じゃないってことだよね
結構できないがなくてまだこれからでなるほどだそう
ビジュがいい月に結婚した意味だとかあるああ
あーなるほどねさんズー
法案とかさあネイルなどでやっぱりどうしてもおじさんリーガー
暇後あの素敵な結婚式をやりたいなって願望はちょっとあったかなぁ
ねぇまぁあのーほんと大好きな youtube やってないんでもう一般的に働いて
いらっしゃいますので
まあその嫁さんどんな人だろうと気になる方はいらっしゃると思うんですけども
詮索は本当にやめていただけると室内地検のためになりますぜひ幸せにチェックを生活
を送らせてあげてください
ぼくらの
さやかなお願いでございますしづらい3結構するためにしておりまだいます是非
[音楽]
ブーブー
たかったかあっていっ
全治考え4 a
引越寸だけを打つい時はネタケルン
トゥーン立てる
終わりございます